[Music]
the element carbon is like a treasure
box
it holds various interesting mysteries
one such unique concept is that of the
homologous series what does it mean
let's understand this in detail let us
get to know the concept by breaking it
into two parts homologous and series one
thought we might have is that it refers
to some series having similarities is it
true yes absolutely in the first part
the word Homo refers to same so in the
case of homologous series we will have
compounds that have something in common
but what is common here we are referring
to the common functional groups what
about the next part that is series for
being in the list of homologous series
the compounds need to occur in a
sequence that means they will occur in
succession and what do we mean by this
let us consider the simpler alkanes like
methane ethane propane and butane are
they in succession you may say yes they
occur one after the other but what
exactly makes them successive to each
other to understand this first tell me
what is the molecular formula for each
the molecular formula of methane is ch4
that's right
ethane is c2h6 and propane is c3h8
and how is butane expressed its
molecular formula is c4h10 now what will
happen if I add ch2 to the molecular
formula of methane it gives me C to h6
right that is ethane and if I add ch2 to
the molecular formula of ethane does
that give me propane yes
adding ch2 to the formula c2h6 gives me
c3h8 which is nothing but propane and
you know the last one adding ch2 to
propane gives us c4h10 that is butane
can you tell me how exactly these
compounds are in series yes they are in
succession and what is the common
functional group among these compounds
needless to say it's an alkane that
means the compounds here will have the
same general formula for example in this
case the general formula for alkanes is
cnh2n plus two so all of these compounds
show this typical general formula right
yes they do
even though they have different
molecular formulae the general formula
is the same and they also noticed a
common difference between any two
successive compounds there's a common
difference of ch2 now that we've
understood the concept let's define the
term homologous series in simple words
it is the series in which two compounds
with the same general formula but
different molecular formula occur in
immediate succession so the hydrocarbons
in the homologous series will have
different lengths of carbon chains but
they will possess the same functional
group and will occur in succession now
tell me one thing
if these compounds are in series with
the same functional group don't you
think their properties will also be the
same well if you said yes then you are
apparently wrong because all the
properties of elements in the homologous
series are not exactly the same the
chemical properties are definitely
similar as they are dependent on the
functional group present however the
physical properties show gradation as we
go higher in the series that's because
the physical properties like the boiling
point melting point solubility and so on
differ with the change in molecular mass
for example a compound with 10 carbon
atoms will have a higher boiling point
compared to a compound with 3 carbon
atoms that's because the energy required
to break the bonds will be greater this
is how compounds in the homologous
series slightly differ from each other
in spite of being in a sequence this was
about the concept of homologous series
seen in the carbon compounds let's talk
about
another interesting concept of isomers
in the next video
[Music]